4,000 Australians were forced onto the
beach and stranded here for three days
now help has arrived for the Victorian
town of mallacoota the Navy ferried
people out by the only route possible
their ship masked in the smokey haze at
the moment we are moving people out boy
I see if the smoke clears we'll be able
to get aircraft into mallacoota to
assist in that transportation of people
out of there as well they have a narrow
window high temperatures and strong
winds are forecast for Australia's
southeast on Saturday leading New South
Wales Fire and Rescue to publish this
map they've advised people to leave the
shaded area from Batemans Bay south to
the Victorian border 250 kilometer
distance down the coast I think the big
thing that we've got underway at the
moment is it's the largest mass
relocation of people out of the region
that we've ever seen and people are
gonna have to be patient on the roads
there people are queuing up to get into
petrol stations through traffic isn't
able to get through thousands heeded the
advice to leave Batemans Bay and drive
north towards Sydney many with nothing
left to save but themselves our house is
gone it's completely burned we found out
yesterday morning for sure we went out
there that the block that we were on has
been burned from one side of the other
this is not a blade of grass on it
there's nothing left about 1,300 homes
have been destroyed in New South Wales
since the fire season began in October
it's been a record-breaking year the
fire's arrived earlier and with more
fury than normal Australian Prime
Minister Scott Morrison countered claims
it's a consequence of manmade climate
change well there's no doubt natural
disasters turned that way Andrew because
that's what they are they are natural
disasters what we're saying is we have
we cannot control the natural disaster
but what we can do is control our
response firefighters are trying to
control the risk by destroying the bush
first back burning to create natural
firebreaks residents prepare
who those choosing to stay gathered
supplies and fuel for generators and
pumps if the wind changes that could
impact quite heavily on my house and my
neighbours and my family's outside but
further family members further up the
road from us so ya know it's basically
these residents restocking preparing to
face the fires head-on